recording in progress so today's meeting
is just to give us a chance to get a bit
more information before we make decision
tomorrow um if we don't make the
decision tomorrow um we go out to the
28th which G just kicks a can down the
road on wner and Russ team need to get
started fairly quickly there um so I
just want him to give us a little bit
more options or advice around option 1 a
which was the sort of halfway step
between sort of bowling it all over
which was option one and option two
which is please leave some of it behind
um but the other thing that's com out in
the report for tomorrow you'll notice is
the issue of the columns and so Russell
just need some advice on that um fairly
sharply because it says that the columns
are under 34% earthquake Prime which
means given that it's right on a
pedestrian Crossing on State Highway I
think we've got some issues here
um but the caveat in the report does say
it depends on the foundations which were
constructed so I guess we'll need I mean
we don't need to make a decision
tomorrow about the columns that could be
an independent decision for later but
just I guess signaling that
um for those that wanted to remove the
columns that's probably going to put a
smile on their face on those that didn't
um but the earthquake Planet issue is
definitely an issue 12 and a half years
though sorry 12 and a half years
you do you're quite right in fact um 12
and a half years is the time you'd have
to strengthen them or remove but it's
like quite a few issues we've had around
around the museum which technically was
25 years but you still have the
emotional issue that what happens if you
get an earthquake and there's five
people standing there wait to go over
the lights and one of the pillars falls
on them yeah and you've known about it
yeah you've got that long to rectify but
there is still that liity yeah yeah I
think if you if you don't have drawings
of the
foundations then it would be the case
every building in the world would be
considered earthqu sure sure y but the
but the 25 criteria does allow it does
mention arterial roads as well which
brings it down to class one which is the
what it would be it would be 12 and a
half years if we decided to leave it and
strengthen it but um just something to
factor in when we get to it and that
could be something we discuss at the
28th meeting
um of council if you can get it back to
us by then Russell yeah thank you could
we shift them to I don't know outside
somebody's Shadow and
Bluff we could use them to
pull how
stable
oh um so Russell if you can lead us
through what we discussed yesterday was
the whole issue around um do you want to
because like rear wasn't here you backg
um
um I'll just flick you this round re you
want to come and get it oh she's got a
copy oh you've got a copy of that yeah
so one of the suggestions we had last
week was leave the clock exactly where
it is you can structurally take
everything out either side of it the
whole
lot um which gives you the visual um
whether You' want to leave the clock
there's one issue but you could get a
bus down the right side and you could
have pedestrian down the left hand side
as you look at the clock the flip side
of that is that down the right hand side
now as you look at the diagram the old
melic building there is Heritage one and
it's got a a veranda that comes out over
the top which complicates things so Jeff
owns
that um so we'd have to if we wanted to
go down that path without moving the
clock we would probably have to uh get a
consent in to remove just the brain
apart so Russell may or may not wish to
talk about that as well um so that was
that was the option between one and two
really three seemed to be off the table
so quite a few of the submit three came
in and said that they wanted the
historical use to be maintained and we
had quite a bit of debate with them
about um so what is it going to be
useful because it's used to nothing at
the moment and they Sugg just why don't
you get School choir Le to sing that and
John Green was here and his advice was
but I think most of a support it was we
moved the Central City away from W place
it's not ideal sitting on a turle Street
um and if we were going to have Cho
singing we'd have them in the middle of
East Street not on not on walking place
but the wind tunnel f is still on the
ship people are still oppose that P to
say that if you look at the reflection
of the people here yesterday and being
an older person I can say this yesterday
Sunday sorry when you say yesterday you
were saying Sunday no when we had the
last when we had sorry yesterday Sunday
you mean that last week last week last
week yeah so um
very much people of my age predominately
coming in who had that historical tie
although the historical tie hasn't been
there that long um and um what the place
is after Mr wman not Mrs wman um but
there's still emotional tie there for
some of the older
people but again on the flip side it we
didn't get anything from the younger
people we've got to be thinking about
how to Future proof our city if there's
no use so
lot of lot of mixed feelings came
through and so one of the things I
suggested was could we go somewhere
between one and two and potentially just
leave the clock there which is for some
of them is an important thing and the
pills were important for some as well um
and just go either side so when you're
looking at that the buses will go down
the right side and the pedestrians will
come down the left side so that means
they coming past the EES so we don't
have buses any near the EES but we have
the foot traffic by the E so it's a
win-win
um Russell will tell you about his
desire not to have a street on the other
side that only has foot pass down one
side but we'll have some discussion
about that
today floor is yours
Russell thanks for the opportunity and I
guess the challenge that that I fa is I
guess a twofold one is the first is not
to introduce new material because I
guess part of what you are doing is as I
understand it is receiving information
from the public consult approach and as
a consequence needing to deliberate and
then actually make a direction and I
guess that the report that you'll have
received actually looks to actually set
some of those directions on the way past
but what I've been asked a little bit to
do is to comment on I guess some of the
GU interactions with
the how things would work around the
clock and um the clock sits it doesn't
sit actually in the middle of the street
if you look at it it actually sits
offset and if you look from the external
you would actually see that the you
either need to go to one side of the
other obviously that's the that's the
that's the suggestion from the mayor is
saying is how do you leave the clock
there you have to go if you go to the
north side um you have a gap between the
clock and melp building of um about just
over 5 meters um a bus itself would um
typically be no wider than um around 2.4
um which sounds quite a lot but typ the
lanes that a bus would operate in is
around the 3 and 1/ half to 4 M would be
a normal sort of bit of bit of space
around them to make some room um the bus
would be 4.2 M wide so we' need to make
a reasonably big hole in there to get
the bus through so it just wouldn't be
to take the glass screen out would
actually to go vertically one of the
concerns that I would have is that as
you drive through there you end up
pointing at a fo at where the normal
people would be walking on the north
side of the um if you were walking from
Leen Street to D
Street um at the moment that's typically
we would have a foot path on both sides
um and I guess that would be one of my
concerns you would actually have the
potential of as a bus come through there
you would as a pedestrian you might well
find You' be standing there and here
comes a bus at you so that's a
reasonable big concern one of the things
that we that you may not necessarily be
aware of is that um before the hours of
the library are open anybody who uses 11
Street building which is about 200
plus people who park there um actually
have to go out of the building to Leen
Street and then circulate around to get
to the city center if that's where
they're going with the car pack so I
guess if you're working at the um
Railway you would wouldn't have to but
if you're working anywhere you have to
walk around so there's quite a few
people who do walk up and down um es
Street West as such and accordingly that
is I guess a pedestrian rout why I would
be suggesting that you'd have a foot
path on both sides it is the normal
structure of your city center um
otherwise it becomes very Centric about
the hotel on one side so if you're
wanted to walk from wherever on on Leen
Street or down to Leen street you may
not want to walk past their door so
that's why I would have a I guess a
little bit of a concern for the bus
being taken that space you have to also
remember if you put the bus on one side
you've got to take the other side out to
actually let the P the pedestrians or
the the visitors from the hotel who want
to exit the hotel who want to come up to
the city because you're not going to use
the same space you're G so the clock
tower is going to sit right in the
middle of the of the street of that you
desire so that's um a possible solution
and I guess that's the challenge to say
is is that the right
solution the alternative solution is
obviously the one to actually remove the
Clock Tower and therefore you would
actually have the buses going in the
position where the clock is do think if
you're there if you notice where the the
1A option with the buses are It's
relatively north of the area so the area
that would be I guess left of the
current space that's widely known as
what in the place would be reduced quite
a lot because the The Arc to get out
there is quite a wide Arc to get there
so you actually consume quite a bit of
that I guess that that space that John
Green showed if you could recall his
diagram he sort of had a blue diagram
which is the space left behind and which
you could develop into a walkner place
use in the future um some form of
passage for vehicle through it and then
you've got your um area in front of the
restaurants that you could use as an
outdoor dining area so I think there are
some compromises to actually bring it to
the north side of the clock I'm not sure
that they are all good compromisers but
they are compromises that you have to
consider um what the report seeks to do
is to
say will you allow buses through walk in
the place and bring back some design
options that actually show you some real
detail because at the moment um we are
playing a little bit with a um a Reas me
fck pencil win a on a pad and we do need
some design consideration to say what is
the Turning Circle are we getting it
right what does it look like coming out
the other
side in terms of The Veranda the mayor's
correct that it would need a resource
consent to remove it from the building
um Jeff Thompson who is the owner of the
building has generally indicated that
would be acceptable however um like all
good developers he would be seeking some
conditions as part of that which aren't
impossible which I think relate to him
being able to modify the building
slightly to double glaze it and things
like that that it part of the Heritage
status of the building would have to be
considered so those are quite possible
um actions and I don't think the veranda
is such that it's actually significant
issue is that sorry is that the building
to the south side or the North side
side it's what we describe is the old
mckillips building M you can see it on
the pictures it's the last one standing
to be fair that's there so so so if
we was taken out the Miranda wouldn't
be
compensation I would anticipate if the
clock if the choice was to remove the
clock or relocate the clock um the
building fanda would stay yeah so we
wouldn't have to do
anything so Russell just we get a whole
lot of questions just two or three
things to reflect on so your opening
statement was the issue that we
technically bring forward another option
that we haven't consulted on so we have
a president for that just so that you
sleep well tonight for tomorrow's
meeting um back in the last term Midway
through the last term we had the issue
of what do we do with the museum the
paper that we put to the community was
strengthen it and reopen it or
rethink 85% said reopen strengthen
reopened it we didn't do either that or
the rethink we voted for a new Museum
when I say we that wasn't me but so we'
said a precedent and I think if if we've
listened to consultations it's
reasonable for a council to tweak where
we go to I think
um can I just make a comment process so
it doesn't necessarily depending on the
scale of what you're doing have to be
something that you've consulted on but
what you consider can be something that
was put forward during consultation or
submissions um if you were going way off
piece from from where you were then
somebody might say oh well that wasn't
what you consulted on but if you are
responding to a suggestion that's come
forward you can say that that is
listening to
consultation my next my next comment is
the issue of having the um foot path
down both sides of the street just some
feedback for you on that one um if I was
coming from the uh city council car park
round the bottom and up through that
space I would definitely not walk on the
North side and the logic for that is if
you leave this building and go to walk
the place the scariest place you cross
over is over the road directly opposite
the h&j car pars CU When you walk over
there cars don't see you and so if you
put a foot path down that side on that
north side you're going to go right over
the opening of his car park and people
by Nature who are coming out and turning
that way
turning towards the raway station I'm
not going to be noticing people coming
from the land I think it would be just
have a single foot but but equally
beside that car park there's an Alleyway
which comes out beside the space ail
house which is what I use when I yeah
and that's the most obvious I mean it's
directly beside the thing and maybe we
could beautify there very obvious but
you come through there I think also I
mean we've defended the the taking buses
across the pavement it worked in place
on the basis that only happen five times
a
day um I mean exactly the same argument
would apply to the little pavement on
the north side of the which is you know
which you which would only have that
issue five times a day you know and I
would have thought that was a much
smaller issue than isue running a bus
across walking place what many you talk
about so at the moment we're planning to
run buses over walk place that's p is
we're not playing it Tom it's one of the
options yes well I mean it's either
option one or what option one a would
run a bus across a pavement um er which
is part of walking place um and through
the Gap so you remove the pavement
completely five times a
day we we're talking about pretty much
exactly the same thing if there's a
North a payment on the North pavement on
the north side of the clock to it's no
different I but but but but also if the
bus is only 2.4 M wide and the gap's 5 m
wide I I don't see why you couldn't have
an AR pement there anyway 4.8 M or 4.2
on it bus that's bus is 4.2 meters high
so um so I guess what I'd be saying is
that where where a bus goes through the
middle of o in the place you have quite
a wide you have a quite a wide area and
it's really it's through a big wide
space whereas this is actually through a
gap and I guess that's the piece that I
think would actually be constrained and
you're correct a slow moving bus will
will it will itself be um not a conflict
but I think it would be a a different
surprise it would be a something you
would see it would be something that
would feel a little bit
different you could trigger a warning
late could a bus runs over there you
certain you certainly could have a
buzzer like h&j Smith would outside the
doorway would drive your nuts and and
beep it all day but that's but other
things you could add to mitigate it but
once again it's still that principle
that you're going through a gap beside a
clock I think we're get
101 let's let's do it let's do it one at
a time one at a time otherwise Russell
can't keep up with the questions so just
no I put my hand up I know I'm coming to
you alen
just I'll slow this down so you can have
your say so so Russell I just can't
understand the principle of having a gap
and that's not say we won't remove the
clock or that won't be one of the
options as as he said but if we leave
the clock there to have a gap that we
encourage a bus to go through knowing
that potentially the pedestrians coming
on the same space I guess that's
more I I think all these things can work
so long as that's the compromise you
want to make and I guess part of what my
job is is to bring bring you both sides
of that story to make sure that you
actually see his balanced a balanced
position um would it work if it was your
only choice yes I guess it's one of the
choices that you have and that and
that's the issue that you need to work
part of the consultation process has
been to say do we want to bring buses
across walk in the place that's really
the first choice and and how that works
whether it be um to the north of the
clock to the south of the clock where
the clock is is just another variation
of each of those and you are to you are
correct that each of those could work
with a degree of compromise we could
make each of those work in some some
area and I guess what you've also got to
watch is that what you get left after
you've done that is what I would be
suggesting what is the place that you
actually get once you finished and um I
guess that's the challenge that we face
if you if you wanted the clock to go to
the north um could it be designed yes it
could
be right the way I think of it is if you
look at Christ Church you've got Kel
Street which has got tra running through
it from time to time inent trams yet the
Isis the time when those trams aren't
running it's a great pedestrian space
and and there doesn't seem to be an
issue they do Dingle ding a bell every
now and then sort of thing and I see I
see what we should be I think what we
should be doing here is something
similar obviously not with TRS but with
that's how the bus would work so I would
be for for putting foot bus on both
sides having it as a nice precin this
pedestrian friendly a bit like street
that we have now and i' move the clock
somewhere else was that it's just so
simple problem is the clock would never
get moved it would get moved to
St and you'd never see it again it's up
to us then to make sure that it does get
moved we are the city
council y hang on we'll have too many
conversations
here I mean today
today's today is not about us having the
discussion tomorrow is about the
discussion today is the questions for
Russell yeah we would have to consider
Russell if the bus was on the North
which is what I had thought I wanted
where does that such where the cars are
coming out of
theor um the the bus would would travel
through through through the gap on the
North side and then it would transition
transition back to the left so is there
not an opening the from the car park at
this end no the opening for the car park
is right down by the Railway Hotel end
it's an in and and out down
that yeah um
you've distracted
me yeah it's gone excellent why he's
thinking about itless he's got one for
you thank you so remind me Russell just
to bring it back into the
conversation what's so terrible about
buses using 11
Street well you know our first decision
is do we put buses through walk a place
at all
so what's the problem really with leban
Street the principle there will be that
the developer wishes for them to be
outside the front door and that's the
only that's the
only statement anyone has ever come up
with so I was wondering if you had
another transport statement that made a
difference here no and I guess that's
why we developed those options to
present in the consultation document
because we wanted to make sure that all
the options that I guess the wider
public would have asked from us have
been explored but during the um the
assessment of the area we came up with
about seven or eight different options
which sort of were vaguely usable in
that area and we focused those down to
three so we had 2A and Es straighten all
sorts of things and we really refocused
those down to those three options that
we put forward in the consultation
document so to sum up the only reason
we're considering
putting buses through walk the placees
because the developer would like that as
their most preferred option they can't
turn so um I can help contribute to that
I guess um because I'm in favor of
option one or one a um and I think that
even if we had option two which is to
pulling off Le Street and have some sort
of shelter there because there is space
here for it or alternative he does a
three-point turn backs backs into front
door which is not ideal in a in a
hoteling but even if you had that what
do we do with walking the place because
at the moment if you leave that huge
structure sitting there people coming
out of the hotel are going to see the
back end of that which is just
disgusting beyond belief and they don't
see estr and what the potential that has
there so yes but the divorcing of the
two things
is why I am raising this because the two
things can be divorced if the only
reason we're even talking about putting
buses through walk the place is because
it's essentially the developers
preference then if it was a council
decision not to do that because Leen
street is another logical thing to do
then yes we do still have a conversation
separately about whether there are some
upgrades to what in a place but you can
actually divorce the two things the
first decision we've got is actually do
we put buses through W the place or not
what's their Council view on doing
that I can see the other hand just
respond to that I guess so sorry to
interrupt no no it's all right look I I
hovered between one and two for quite
some time and you know where my home s
so she's in two um but I been down there
several times recently and looked from
11 Street upwards towards where we want
people to be which is in the CBD and CBD
is not walking a place that's beyond and
if I was coming out of that hotel uh I
don't think I'd be attracted towards a
street because doesn't matter how much
we paint walking the place up it's still
a big big solid piece of architecture
just sits it's a barrier yeah so yeah
P I'm just bouncing off your um C or
there LLY so I
mean was there any consideration that
the door based basically the the railway
station Le Street was even consideration
for the um yeah and the other one is
really around there's nothing stopping
us if we wanted to make it more
attractive open up one side of walk
place for people to walk through from
the hotel and make it
attractive so I think perhaps I could
clarify the question that I was asked
was was it was there any concern about
the buses using because street at the
moment prior to the development was a
street that's open to traffic and was
very very um nonp people friendly and I
guess we've sort of suddenly gone to the
step of saying was we don't want cars
well I guess you might have to cons also
consider as part of that that that area
if it was if the buses weren't there
that could be just be returned to a a
car parking environment for access to
and from the car park so that could be
what you're suggesting is could a bus
stop be added to 11 Street yes could it
re be returned turned to um just the
parking Arrangements that were prior to
that certainly it's um I think you've
got to look at all those decisions does
that actually bring value could it be
opened up there's a whole lot of those
things and that's really what we're
saying is that the first question you do
have to ask is whether the buses go
through what place yep and that will be
tomorrow's absolute discussion because
you I'll come to the because I L this as
well um we will have to make a decision
on one versus two I suspect
and then if the if the majority in favor
of one then the next question will be do
we modify one or do we just leave it as
one the one the way it is at moment
which is basically flatten everything
and create um this end of air street
down the other end same sort of thing
shared shared spaces which is what
they've got in Queenstown and all the
inner city streets in Queen the whole
lot of or all this shared space where
you can take a vehicle through the
middle very slow I think it's a about
5Ks or something like that um and people
sit around and mingle so it's not
pestering at the cost of vehicles or the
other way around it's both but the
traffic is so slow through all those
five six streets now that nobody goes
through it it's just not worth it so I
guess that's we will get to this
tomorrow com
com one
uh Russell I mean some of what I been
thinking has been se but
not to put too f a point on it I have
stayed over the years at hotels that are
heavily dependent on bus traffic and I
have talked to Hotel owners and managers
about the benefit of bus tours they come
in at 7 or about 5 or 6 or whatever they
go to their rooms they go and eat in the
Hotel dining room and they're out again
at half 7 or 8:00 in the morning so
being sold the idea that they're going
to go and Riot around town and spend
heaps and heaps of money at that time of
the window of opportunity that they
have is I don't think a valid comment
and we should actually think seriously
about it as an argument however the
other concern I had is in one of the
designs that and I I've been looking I
can't actually find it now but there was
a draw um drawing of the port cier which
shows cars driving down the road on the
left hand side which means that it looks
like they entered from D Street so
whilst we're talking about buses I don't
think this is necessarily what everybody
thinks is going to result out of all of
this somebody somewhere thinks that cars
are going to drive up and down that part
and they're going to go and park under
the PK cier or now they can do that if
they come off Le stet into um lower oh
thank you leely and turn
around but buses that come from
distinction hotels are coming from eano
where they could come down Le Street or
they're coming from denen or Points
North where they could come in through
the Cresent onto leeven street I'm
totally opposed to this city altering
things just for this purpose when that's
not where the design um thinking of the
inner city has been going this is
actually taking away from The Pedestrian
friendly
um citizen friendly spaces that we've
been developing in E Street and Dawn
Street it's not contributing to the what
um great beautification of D Street
which was going to be after finishing
off celvin Street we we're going to
prioritize what is actually going to
benefit basically one business his Port
Kier he is responsible for and he owns
both sides of the
street why isn't the onus
on je to provide
that visitor welcome in that
lower EET space with impacting on what a
place at all because it's not just what
a place it impacts on D Street as
well and that's where I'm at I and just
and I guess um two things for tomorrow
um I guess we have to be very careful
that we don't tag Jeff in this he's just
a developer who we've encouraged to come
into the City and brings touris in I
don't personally believe that they'll be
here late at night and go first thing in
the morning why would they come here if
they weren't staying for some reason
they go to Tiana they go out and trip
they go to denen they go out the
peninsula and other places if you look
at his hotel and denen classic example
of how not to do it right he's got it
right down the wrong end of town when I
go and stay there and I regly do I don't
go out of the hotel because there's
nowhere to go too I quite like to go to
the inner city and go to a movie go to a
restaurant but it's up and over the hill
and down in the
and most days it's too bloody hard going
so I just stay in the hotel so yeah I
don't think he's going to bring them all
away from Queenstown or to out just to
have an overnight here and be gone the
following morning I think the people
will stay and we'll get some kick back
into Bluff and to St and plac to the
Transport Museum but never mind I add a
little bit to that is that I've included
in the report um the sections of what
the porter shed does look like so you
can see what's being proposed I guess
the plans that we had seen to date
hadn't necessarily shown where it was
what it looked like an elevation and
they've been included so you can get a a
good perspective of the scale of what's
being proposed to wear because it does
to be fair take a piece of the um es
Street in front of the the hotel um it
does mean that the space between the car
park and the hotel becomes more car
Centric because there will be cars
trying to do some Maneuvers at times
through that and that's what the purpose
of those cross-sections in your report
are there to actually help you
understand that area in Greater detail
so that as you consider that that you
you have seen the information that's
currently
available come up Peter and and just as
a final reflection for me we have a lot
of debate about us taking something away
and not replacing it and I don't see
what we take wa to be quite honest I've
gone down there again every lunch time I
can physically get there nobody is in
Walking place like
nobody so what are we doing we heard
people say oh you should get school
choirs to go down look we can get a
school choir to go and sing they sing at
the outcome in the middle of E Street
where it's nice and sheltered um and has
a lot of foot traffic why would you go
and sing and walk in the place because
nobody's going to come here but you know
Peter spend a bit of time down at walk
the place over the last two weeks and I
I
haven't what were you dressing I was my
anomer yeah okay uh one option Russ
option one or one a the toilets will in
the changing room and there will shares
remain the same or similar yeah
St there's no proposal to CH there's no
proposal to change that that doesn't
preclude you and
you as fur development in the fure there
is current what we put on the table at
the moment there is no change those
areas so Peter we earlier had a meeting
at one of the earlier meetings we
discussed that and the intention was to
leave them there because people that are
rough sleeper things use the Shar so
there's no intention to take that away
are they the ones that AR sorry
blacklisted or sorry trespassed yeah
well that that it does create some
issues I understand stand there y from
the from the toet yes yep Tom an
interest there a this is a question
um my originally my view was that I
supported Leen street because it was the
least cost in fact I don't see why it
should be any cost to the city to do it
and at a time when we're trying to save
money so certainly the least disruptive
to the city now I think when we went out
to um when we we went out to public
consultation and when you read you know
what the public said you know they
they're concern they supported option
two they did not support option one and
overwhelming numbers have supported
option two but the main concern I think
when I read it was about you know
protecting the clock tour which is more
LED than I think we realize and even a
lot of people who wanted to protect the
columns so and my mind I suppose I had
kind of come around to Option 1 a in the
sense that maybe it was a compromise
where you could get you could protect
those Heritage things that people want
to protect um and yet at the same time
provide good access to the city so my
question coming to that question is on a
straight let's say a black Lan basis
right is option one a
possible yes okay thank you right
I think we have to remember that we have
to pull out walk in the place regardless
because we've got infrastructure that
needs replacing so even if we wanted to
leave it as it was it's not going to be
that way so it seems sensible to do
something and I have been in the city
for 65 years I have never since you were
10 no I was in in the country before
that I have never been to a
function um walk
place um that may be me but I'm just
saying that I am also part of the
community and that's been my experience
and when I travel and stay in hotels I
never eat hotels ever I always go and
find a place so that's I'm just saying
Evelyn that's a different view from what
you
have oh tour buses tend to have
packages it's different than being a
freedom and u a freedom traveler that
was my point which what came from um
Hotel managers but I respect your point
too yeah yeah so Russell the yeah I've
see all the hands um Russell the other
thing you raised was about um going to
the right of the clock where we rode
into the north side of wner and again my
observation is that the what little
traffic there is that sits in Wagner
doesn't sit on the North side cuz it's
shaded so if you notice the seats down
the moment they all got green slime all
over them and to me that would have been
an ideal place to maybe put a small ice
enter in in that space so we wouldn't
need as much there where maybe having a
little bit more on the Southside would
be a bit better I think what I was
really referring to is if you think
about the the path that a bus would
sweep between D Street and there the
further you go north the more the more
of that that wide area is consumed and I
guess just in the paper we speak a
little bit about um we talk about what
the place being the whole area but I
guess there's there's several several
Parcels there there's the section which
used to be the Smith and rainford
building which is the the corner which
is truly wner place yes the the other
lots to the south of it are lots that
were formed when the road was stopped in
the 80s and there's a there's a small
section to the very south of that which
is where the Telecom building was so
that sort of and to be in the day to-day
operation um for from From council's
perspective we've called it wner place
because they all stick together um so
that's but I'm just saying is that if
you imagine where the if I drew a line
where the bus would travel the further
you go to the north the more it consumes
The Wider area and takes and takes a
path where you have to have potentially
I guess an interaction between the two
sure okay right and
then yes written it down so you've
written it
down me um so through the about the
consultation I went to the cing thing
for the city on Saturday night and
purposely asked everyone I spoke to
about what the place and no one was
worried about walking the place going
right so I think we got to be careful
around the
submissions that it's 171 people of
21,000 rate payers and 50,000 people so
and I've asked a number of people that
talk to and equally you have and you
know we've just got to balance out the
submission pece versus the water of
voice and maybe that silent voice but
Russ with there's no way the buses can
go to the south side of the
clock as I said equally I believe the
buses could go to the South side but you
would then equally compromise the
opportunity um I guess the greatest
opportunity could be for a space in
front of the two restaurants to be fair
which have no legal right to have space
there yeah um but it is the logical
place that for you going to have an
outdoor dining area you'd have it on
that side of those premises that's the
you know you read it and it's the it's
the place which gets the maximum sun
it's the it's the whole it's the whole
logical pie a curve too wouldn't it it
would be but it's still quite a possible
ter because I think from the
consultation I've separated out the
preser wner Y Legacy which you know come
through loud and clear of thinking the
submissions
in the public
space and you know so I think we've
somehow got to think about how we
preserve that Walkman Legacy and um
John's drawing that he put up had a
bigger space to the north side which is
where the 1A goes through and what I've
seen in that was the ability to preserve
that
wner public space there right but I
think in my mind I've separated out the
public space very clearly the public
wants somewhere that they can congregate
somewhere in the city at some stage in
the future I don't know um if it has to
be tomorrow and then but like Tom said
the tars come through quite strong in
the consultation for mine I was quite
surprised about how the Heritage
piece that they represent how strong
that comes through and the clock equally
and so to Ellen's Point we've probably
got to think
through you know um several of those
things separating out preserve the wner
and where do we have a public space and
then if it means the clock goes we need
to make a commitment to put it up not on
the museum R
um and
um and the tears I'd like to think I
understand that you know the issues
around the earthquake thing but you know
it' be nice to see them preserve too
based on what I've heard from the some
of the consultation but that's just my
summary of sort of I'll come across the
DAR in a minute and you're right I think
some previous advice we had was that if
we went to the left of the clock the
turn would be too tight as we go into
that space and would involve more than
one lane so they'd swing out a little
bit to around that sort of right angle
corner where the other one going to the
right of the clock you can Arc across
cut that slip way
through well equally if you people
coming into the city from Liv Street on
that South Side you got a real conflict
there if you're to the right AR you
because the bus is there whereas it's
more C or 1 a you're sort of pushing the
bus to one side and the people have got
a natural pathway I think what you're
saying is strategically is do you want
to go around the clock or not and I
think there is a conversation about the
clock um I met there with the one of the
gentlemen from previously from Bond
contracts who actually rebuilt the clock
um and got the um the history of the
clock was he's um the two guys who built
it actually still are around him um and
they found the clock mechanism um in a
box in the water tower in the 80s and it
had all the bits it just had no shafts
nothing connected they were just in a
box and that was how that that was how
it was and guess what they did is they
took they took the mechanisms and they
actually put it together and figured out
how to make it work work and and I think
most people who go and look at the clock
actually see the mechanism with the
pendulum swinging in a glass box that's
sitting
there and that's a mechanism that could
sit somewhere there or elsewhere um so
I'm saying is that the mechanism itself
is the piece that's really valuable to
us um I think there's pieces of the you
know the bells and the and the clock
faces they all have versions of
history but the things that are actually
the historic value are the actual the
bells the clock faces and the mechanism
itself how where it fits how it goes
what it does as I guess in the 80s was
deemed to be there um and if you look at
the structure it's quite a dominant
structure and I guess if you sit back a
little bit and say what does it actually
want what what does it actually mean to
us is is that really its place is that
the right place but most people when
they go there they look at the clock
mechanism in a glass box and moment if
you look around there there's quite a
lot of work to be done we haven't had a
lot of love in that area um and it does
need a lot and it's one of those um
lovely clocks that needs somebody who
goes every Sunday morning at
11:00 and adjusts the time to correct it
and that's what these guys have done for
the
last last 25 or 30 years unseen
unbeknown Bown to our community up until
recently more recent times 10 years
they've adjusted that clock every Sunday
morning hopped in and just opened the
door climbed in set it back to 11 o'cl
and away she went and none of us were
any of the wiser that someone was
adjusting
it
and so I'm going to come to in a minute
Darren just and you're right grant um I
think one of the things we had when we
went out to consultations we required to
give a preference so we did that even
though we tried to qualify I think if
we've gone out and said look don't want
to touch walk it's it's a precious gym
in the middle of the city um we want the
bus to go in off Lemon Street we
probably would have got just as many
people coming in in what a waste of
space that is look why don't you just
Bowl it over and modernize it but
because we had the preference that
people tend only the people that
disagree with us tend to come in yeah
that's been my experience we had the
same stuff with the museum as well
whatever attack you take on the museum
is detractors want to come and the one
supporting just think I will Council
will do what they want
anyway
Darren um kind of Sidetrack but but not
and and that's the conversation around
uh Jeff and and his expected
contribution and having stayed at a few
um hotels across the years I guess the
thing that intrigues me most
about this one is that Jeff who's a
businessman is capitalizing on an
opportunity that exists now that didn't
previously and that is to exploit the
increasing number of reasons to stay in
inago to not only get people to his
hotel but to stay for more than one
night so there are those tour companies
who sweep through they aring at night
you've gone and done your package tour
you get to your room you go into town
you have a meal at Cafe you come back go
to bed and at 7 o'cl you're back out
again buffet
breakfast that's not necessarily what I
see them trying to do there'll be people
who'll be leveraging off to um Stewart
Island but there are an increasing
number of people who were using the
facilities in town to stay for a while
and that's why normally I go lot if a
lot of this and apart from the
replacement of the infrastructure is
about
facilitating things that benefit Jeff's
business I'm not a great fan of that but
at the same time as a business person I
go
well I'd like to see a little return on
my investment into the community as well
and so that's how I can live with with
um reshaping what it is at wner
Place Peter and I have been challenged
um by submissions over many years when
when you get lobbied and and there's a
degree of having to um to learn how to
filter the noise without ignoring what
it is that's being
said uh the people who are really
passionate about walking a place that
presented and those are the ones who
will resonate in your mind as opposed to
those that hopefully you've read who
didn't want to speak to theirs are
talking about things historic and not
things that have happened there recently
and Grand plans about getting School
choirs to come down and sing are not
couched in reality at all because you
try and get a school who prepared to get
a bunch of kids onto a bus after filling
out the paperwork and getting all the
consent youve got a bloody Miracle let
alone to come and entertain who for 20
minutes sure you could do some things
and and really the last
big thing apart from public protests and
they are the most uh frequent events
that happen in walk place and I think we
need to recognize there needs to be a
space for that voice to be expressed
because we don't want it outside our
bloody building like we had for a while
um that there's there's some some need
for that but the Buscus Festival was the
last thing that went on there BS don't
want to play there it's not an
entertainment venue the kids the only
time kids gather there is before they do
the Orange Walk which is all the The
Pedestrian Crossing kids and they walk
from there down to here and then no will
give them an ice cream send them on
their way and um but that's
it so couching that that history but
finding a
way I I think it's absolutely essential
that we do continue to recognize the
wner
history I'm a little more ambivalent
about the towers of knowledge or pillar
of knowledge or whatever they are
Celtics things Celtics a football team
um and not a very good one no no no um I
I'm
intrigued more united because um I'm
intrigued by the fact that there is the
potential um road hazard which you know
across all that time I've never really
thought of but depending on which way
the Earth is moving it's probably very
real but given the event would take to
bring them down there's probably a
reasonable degree of masonry it's going
to be heading State Highway SE as well
um so it's not going to be an
easy discussion tomorrow ahead of it I I
think one of the things that will
probably come out if we have the same
kind of conversation that we're having
today is that people will see their
council's considered all options and
that's the stuff you should sleep easy
about remember to
express so I got one question for you
then and it's really around that I think
you partially answered it before but
it's a little bit around that if we
consult on three options and those three
options quite specific can we go to a 1
a or 2A or 3A or whatever I think we can
that's believe we can yep okay without
going back without going
back we are amending what we put forward
based on the feedback that we' had and
that's that's a local government
requirement yeah that you consult
consult and you can't deviate Too Much
from the consult no it's on the degree
of deviation so if you're coming up with
something that is completely Blue Sky
yeah wasn't raised or suggested yeah
through the consultation and feedback
yeah that that would be different but
you had people presenting different yes
different options for for the traffic
flow and so you're expanding on on that
in your consideration of what it is
where you want to land you could justify
because sub ra that yeah you're picked
up on that right so provid we're in the
same fiscal envelope and within the same
sort of yeah within the same sort of
dialogue we would be okay the scale
hasn't hasn't really changed yeah yeah
yeah the very far away yeah I'm I'm I'm
quite happy with a onea solution to that
um as Trish said and we we've all seen
what the infrastructure changes have got
to be with new p and everything one of
those pipe work I think it was the
septic line it was right in the middle
of that
clock but we could get under it though
with a bit of luck we y y yes yes he
said yes to that the last meeting he did
yeah blow it through I think is what he
refer to just just to probably put a
little bit more I've speak spoken at
length with their drainage teams and um
the sewer main does go under the clock
Foundation base so the pipe is
relatively deep there are certainly
techniques that would allow us to be
able to avoid having to dig a big hole
um it may well be that um there are
those we use those more extensively um
yes to Str reflect a little bit uh that
was the technique we had originally
planned to use in the s s Street between
Kelvin and D Street because we believed
it was going to be fast cost efficient
and a great way to do it um when we
started and actually did some further
investigation the pipe wasn't suitable
but for a short length through there it
is quite possible you can either burst
the pipe draw the pipe pull the pipe
there's there's ways to get under the
clock on the way past so um in terms of
the level of disruption of the
services we just need to make sure that
we understand once we start walking the
place and how we tie it in and that's to
be fair no different than anywhere else
we'll try to make good whatever the
level of finishes going back if I could
be perhaps just a little bit of room
here um I would really like to make sure
that we actually understand the clear
Direction around the clock because um
one a or otherwise I just I just need to
I guess my preference is I need to
understand what sort of design we have
to do but it's around it's around what
we actually have to go around rather
than what the design looks
like I think you get tomorrow the
purpose of what walk in the place is is
one of the key things that we um have
consulted
on so P I'm going to come back to you
about the fiscal stuff because some you
said that before in a minute paron you I
just want to sort of come back to to
what Grant said around you know all R
payers you know and other people and
I've spoken to lots of people and about
walking a place as well and I mean you
know the you're right there is that
historical type attachment but there's
also that one of the things that we
haven't sort of talked about was is
really the wind wind tunnel literally we
really haven't if we opened up the whole
thing in any
W um the other thing is we were just
talking about foot paths on north or
south or both so really that's going to
determine if we make a decision on one
or one a um my preference has always
been to Li Street for because I think
that the developer you know could have
easily put a door on the side of that
and entered that way for that reason um
I think with the infrastructure that's
needing to happen which um you've just
spoken about it's not meaning that we're
needing to rip up the whole of over the
place to to do that infrastructure it's
a piece of that correct it's two strips
yep it's just two strips yeah I mean in
any like replacement infrastructure it
would be within that that area so not
really the whole concept but like I said
I I think it's important we also take in
consideration those that who actually
did go along and put in a submission I
think it's still important to listen to
their voices we did we have including
I'm just saying you know St two strips
of two me and majority was so that
doesn't matter I know that I'm just
saying so just on the issue of the wind
um I went back to uh Bob Simpson again
and I know people are going to get upset
with me even talking to him at times
because um but he actually gave me some
very good advice which I already knew
about anyway which means that as you as
wind hits the structure it's not like
water water hits a structure it then
spreads out wind doesn't if it hits a
structure it goes over the top as you
stand on the lewood side you get the
shelter but it eventually comes down and
and you see that as wind passes over the
southern outs it does exactly that um so
I said to him so how far up would I go
before that wind just becomes normal
again and he said by the time you get to
the other side of D Street the wind will
come over the structure and pick up
speed again so if you take it out you'll
get a wind tunnel effect right with the
old stages and I know that because I
walked through that for about 10 years
um but once you get to EST Street the
wind that you got there will not be
affected by the structure or Not by the
structure because the structure is not
all that high taking out the clock the
structure either side of the clock is
not that high everybody's forget what L
said before too like that structure is
so ugly from behind it's terrible if you
had a look at it so it really it makes
the whole bottom of e that bit of Street
there terrible horrible but taking out a
piece of it and making it pu
purification yeah what up it attractive
um just remember when if option one of
the if the clock was to remain you will
need to remove I believe both sides of
the infrastructure the clock would have
to sit as a standalone piece in the
middle because pedestrians or people
leaving the
hotel aren't necessarily going to try to
funnel through the where the buses are
so you will end up with quite a wide
opening and yeah that could in fact um
I'm not a wind engineer but you just
have to watch that you don't actually
make it worse yeah um I also think that
you um counc Arnold's right is when you
stand at low Street um in the 80s we
destined a lot of those buildings to
actually have less patronage by and we
chut them off from the city to be fair
with what we did and I guess the back of
them hasn't necessarily been I guess
given too much treatment from a view of
how if you stood there what would it
look like and I think any of the
proposals will need to actually have
some consideration of how does it
actually connect and I guess that's what
we're saying is how does how does this
piece of Street actually continue we've
been pretty brave to actually attack is
and Don and I don't think we realize as
a city How brave we have been to take on
what we've done and get there and I
guess for my own self provision survive
the retailers because to be fair there
you go everywhere else and and what
we've done is something huge compared to
what um we would otherwise do queen
toown and Eden I mean um the disruption
that we have been able to get through as
a city and actually come out the other
end and have something
magnificent what we need to do is make
sure we actually understand fully how we
connect on there and and I guess John
Green if he was here I'm sure you'll be
saying is make sure you're as Brave as
as we have been to actually achieve that
because we fear as a city we have been
pretty brave to do what we do I guess
it's actually how do you put that in
that decision- making process sorry yeah
down that end too you've got three
buildings now you've got the railway
station which is recognized even though
it's built in 75 it's recognized
historic building you got the raway
hotel which is probably one of the best
examples of Victorian building in in
viago that's had to put up with all that
for years and years and years now you
got this new hotel that's just on the
the other side I mean that whole end of
that bit of street is is actually quite
a
magnificent there's magnificent things
around there it's just it's just going
to get better and better I mean it's
it's
great so the other side is the issue of
the
fiscal estimates that are there that's a
a pain factor for this Council I guess
want to a bit of words notice in your
paper that goes forward to tomorrow it
does talk about some potential to reduce
I mean I just can't understand if we if
we go to option one um and and if we're
only paying up to where the clock
currently is and and if we're not
factoring in infrastructure your
infrastructure Ro underground stuff how
can be $15 $15
million
um M Mr day and I have had had a
conversation about how I want to answer
that this question with it coming and I
guess that's and with with ke I guess
what we understand is that the the
developer has responsibilities to
reinstate the damage that he's done on
low Street sure um because we've given
him the opportunity to use some of those
areas to construct which isn't unusual
we've done that elsewhere so that's why
there's Gates on those sorts of things
there is a need to reinstate back to
what I guess a like for
like anything beyond that I guess we
haven't necessarily facted into it i' I
asked the quantity surveyors who did the
work with us on Dawn and Es Street to
prepare us an estimate that allowed for
um what a full ref refurbishment of wner
place and a full refurbishment of of E
Street to a standard that um looked like
E Street but was of the cost and quality
of Dawn Street with inflation so I'm
trying to get the bast of everything and
that's what the 14.6 at this stage we
haven't necessarily identified what the
cost allocation would be through that
process beyond that but what we do know
is that there are um certain areas
within the lower s Street piece from the
clock to 11 Street and around 11 street
where the developer has a responsibility
to reinstate um you might say what does
that mean um if you'd been down there
that the uh surface that we had were
Paving blocks Circa 1986 that were
crumbling there were planting gardens so
the level that we would actually
reinstate that he could reinstated
to might well be um well below what I
guess any visitor to our city might
expect so I guess that's the question
can I ask I don't understand that one
because clearly he is not going to put
down old broken bits of right he's going
to lay a new piece of road can put down
an old piece of road unless he's got it
upheld up somewhere he's going to put it
back down he's going to put down a a new
road and that's the only thing that's
required in in lores
Street we don't need anything else other
it and I guess that's the design
standard of what we actually want to do
is tie it in how much beautification how
much how many Gardens we want that's
that's what we need to do and that could
be that could well be um no cost to the
city but that's I guess part of what you
need to
actually you need to negotiate and
understand where it
is I guess my unas is when I look at all
three options they all come with very
large price ranges and if I just
speaking personally for myself if I
think that wner doesn't have any
intrinsic value to the city and others
will argue otherwise but for me it
doesn't doesn't serve a purpose going
forward um why the hell would I be
putting 14 156 million into
it don't quite get
there any mind just I TR
Peter yeah on the day of the uh
submissions one of the submitters namely
Bob Simpson y uh he was n correct with
what he said and you said
you've spoke to him since sure that the
wind goes up and come straight down well
it does not no I didn't say that well he
said
it comes down no what he what he said
was if you if you if you
take that as being the Southern Alps
sitting on the South Arm the wind goes
up there it doesn't stay up there it
eventually drop down wind does that
if you sit there you got
sh wind and that makes no difference at
all you go right I'll tell you I done a
reading of the wind y uh on the 26th of
October at noon Y and it was a very
strong direct Westerly
wind
53 the reading was I go into wner place
and actually a father asked me what I
was doing it was a Mr hurle that throws
his hat in the air and I told him I was
measuring the wind I go up East Street
and the wind was steady it wasn't Bluff
Street it was steady 53k I go up outside
westpack in the middle of the street it
was between 15 and 18 K so it hadn't all
come down and you go right up to the the
old Cambridge Place entrance into the
into the um new mall still Leed
and it was between 15 and 18 right up
there until you come to the Calvin hotel
and it was just through so what he's
saying is not correct it doesn't all
come again where does it go I'm buger if
I
know but my
um well I guess my my little Gadget
measures the wind is is accurate to two
degrees if you if you watch if you watch
car racing frames good example when they
test cars they have those windels that
you go into and you can you can track
the air flow and air will move over a
car but it does drop off and does
doesn't move over this height because
that's how the car and stay there
because otherwise you have a
negative well that's how wind's created
it's two different variations of
pressure so by putting a
structure I don't I don't think any of
us have a clue actually well I tell you
what I use we really should get I mean
I've got a clue I've got facts no no I
wasn't meaning up here what was meaning
this in terms of you know engineering of
wind whatever they call I don't even
know they're nameing it right but there
but clearly there will be experts you
could get advisor and if that was a real
concern you could get experts nobody in
ISRO is an expert Bob Simpson certainly
not an expert because he and I talked
about it too he doesn't know either
really he just expressed an opinion same
as we are
use the here it is accurate
2% I've done it I've got I've logged it
I've logged the other days too so I know
what I'm talking
about thank you pet I Le something then
um so throughout I I get what you mean
Daren about submitters um I mean I was
originally in favor of option two um so
that we could satisfy the needs of our
city plus that of being realistic into
what the developer requires um but since
then thinking about the columns and how
people want to hold on to that that they
the feeling out there in the public is
that they don't want us to check out
their history and be inconsiderate to
the very people that what in the place
is um named after so I I'm in favor of
keeping the columns where they are I
never thought I'd say that but I have
since changed my mind the Clock Tower
and reading the history behind that and
knowing the two gentlemen that um fixed
that in the 1980s and then again um
looking after it since then I mean I am
in favor of moving it um to somewhere in
a better location um to give us uh a
more modern beautiful what in a place
the 14.6 million that's been estimated
is only an estimate none of those costs
are actual um certain Stone yet they're
not concrete as to what I understand
with the report so you know that cost
could go down or that cost could go up
but since sitting here and looking at
your Option 1 a and looking at the
structure that is around that clock I'm
you know I'm also in favor of keeping it
where it is and taking down the areas
that um
are beautifying like the concrete panal
areas the um the back of it so that it
can be beautified modernized that
decided for the bus to go through maybe
some cured walls around here to break
that structure of that wind blowing
through I'm I completely and utterly
know that when you're behind there it is
ugly so we're going to need to do
something anyway regardless so we need
to think about it strategically cost
effectively what is it being what would
be the best way to deal with us and
where we are still taking in mind what
the general public that did submit
because they are the voices that
bothered to come here um and others that
have actually said that they want to see
it beautified um they want to either see
the clock stay or go fix modernize The
Columns the problem that I've heard the
argument too is that nothing happens
there one of the submitters got it right
it's because it's not attractive we
don't actually draw any draw cards there
I've been there for many times
protesting political um me too oh I've
been there many times I've been there
with South girls high school when we
went there to um discuss or make the
public aware of issues that that we were
having we know to keep the shoes or not
um you know so I I have I've been there
many times plunker mothers with babies
with car seats a mother that came to all
of our schools around New Zealand to
make sure that we were cycling with hat
on because her son was killed you know
that that has been utilized but our
needs have changed in the future we've
got Digital Play taking part in our kids
lives that they're not there as often as
what they used to be they used to be a
video arcade that i' go and jam space
and V games at um at J or whatever it
was called across the road you know so I
do understand that we haven't and it may
be that there's a flavor or appetite
within this building that it's not
utilized now that we've got es and Dawn
Street but your public are going to want
to go protesting somewhere the shock was
going to be happy for us to do that
right outside their shots on E Street
are they going to be happy that there's
congregations happening where people are
not happy unions want to argue over the
low rages of our Healthcare sector you
know so I think that we can make this
work we just have to be really smart
about it and make sure that we're
delivering to all of our community and
the developer but make sure there's a
healthy
balance Short
History what happen with the red shoes
i' still shoes they're still there I've
still got M tradition is important oh
it's
nothing so but what was important then R
was it important you could that you
protested or that you want to remember
the place that you
protested it was important that we you
went there you knew that you could hook
hook into the sound system that you knew
that as you were protesting and you had
your your microphone or what have you
your your boards that you were visual
from the traffic coming past people
would honk their horns in support of you
so it's not it's that was your Gathering
point do you see in the designs though
anywhere where that couldn't happen well
I'm thinking if we're going to modernize
it and if we do keep the clock where it
is the protests are all run up against
the street they don't they don't sit
back under mostly when you are speaking
to your protests and your gathers you're
inside this area here you're always on
the stage and then the people the public
are out and they are either on the side
with their playards or what have you um
yeah and and so you are utilizing that
wider space as well depending like the
tppa massive protest there you know and
there were hundreds of people there we
can't ignore that when you are emotively
like consumed to do something about what
the best of your country is for the
future you'll get your feet down there
right and you will
protest and and one of the things R is
saying is I think that at the moment we
aren't offering anywhere else for that
purpose place is still the only place to
do
that stage
stage
not for what R and I experienced is the
well you just going to stand on and talk
you can't go down Dawn Street because
there's a
courthouse a
stage where is it I W down time
SE that's not a stage stage that's
a that's not a stage go to other cities
see
stagea put into no you wouldn't you
wouldn't put it into e Street's going to
have the
last and then just about The Columns of
that seismic testing with the
32% why 3% sorry no the results say
below 34% which means it's not legal
okay so it's debatable because we have
de that's all right but as I said we
won't have don't to have that discussed
tomorrow we can leave that till the 28th
or whenever you needed a clock don't
need clocks anymore everybody's got a
clock on in the pocket but there's
nothing like it's a movement it's a
movement yeah it's like walk Peter it's
a lot cheaper no not the movement of a
person the movement Evelyn's gonna have
the last say and then we're going home
because we're GNA have this debate again
tomorrow Evelyn your last chance Last
Word birthday lady happy birthdayy
birthday yes thank you your sh we're
going the
B Mr I'm going to defend you um no I
think the thing the cost involved in the
standard maintaining the standard of
design and
presentation is actually an important
part of this discussion and the
commitment that we haven't got from the
developer is whether that is a place
that he is prepared to meet us at so if
we as a council as a community agree to
option one onea which allows the buses
through you then we will be obligated to
elevate the design in lower es Street to
meet that of at least as somebody said
the other day that of Dawn Street um so
not quite as high perhaps as uper E
Street but so that's the things like the
rain Gardens and and the quality of the
seating and all those sorts of things
now if that's what we're prepared to
commit to we've got to be prepared to
pay that on our own because there is no
guarantee that the developer will meet
us at that place and I think that that
in itself is something that if I'm
thinking as a resident and a citizen of
this place that I am concerned about
that we're being asked to make that
investment not because we are choosing
to but because that is a consequence of
the decision that we're going to have to
make now if we don't make the decision
to allow buses through if we say that
that is the developer's responsibility
and he does it in the areas that he
already owns Which is both sides of
lower E Street then the consequences of
the costs are different they the costs
of relocation of the clock or um
upgrading of the Clock Tower or
redesigning the um Furbish Ms of wner
place and that's a whole different
discussion and probably um still a
reasonably expensive cost but could be
more staged and you know not so forced I
feel like we're being forced and that's
a position I find myself uncomfortable
about that it's not a decision that
we've come to organically because that's
what we chose but that we're being made
to make this decision out of sequence
with what we had planned so um leaving
aside all the things that I like about
the historic things the value that I see
and young people being able to see the
mechanics of the clock all those sorts
of things which I see value in and I've
expressed that but being purely
pragmatic on behalf of this Council if
we are going to maintain the quality
because Russell talked about how Brave
we've we have been as a council in the
last few years about the decisions and
we're reaping the benefit of that in
terms of what people are saying about
our Inner City development we would be
letting ourselves down if anything that
we do on the other side of of esque
street is not of the same
standard so that's you know the cost of
that and do we take that down to leeven
Street if we have to take it down to
leeven street with no guarantee of any
um and co-investment by the developer
that's the risk that you're you're
deciding tomorrow isn't it
really um well I'm not sure about that
and one one of the things we had was we
had some discussion a couple of weeks
ago about whether we would try and
factoring some uh commitment from JF to
what what he would do or wouldn't do and
I said no to that because I think that
the moment you allow his dollars to
become involved you're accused of him
buying the city
council buying your boates we if we want
to risk taking the clock out and going
through we risk that we have to upgrade
if he contributes that's great if he
doesn't he
doesn't we can certainly be forceful
with him but he will certainly have to
repair what he's done down there to a
certain standard it may not be a
register of what we' currently got in a
street and that's where the debate will
come in but he certainly won't just be
able to leave it focus focus and just
because he wouldn't want to do that Dev
Valu all property by doing
it tough decision for
tomorrow and I guess the way probably
approach it is is look at the options
and have a vote on the options one two
potentially three if you want to have
three but it seems like it's one or two
if the option is in favor of one and and
only if it's in favor of one then I'll
put up the option of a one 18 as a
consideration and you would you got an
appetite to have that if that's the opt
if the option is two then two it
is one uh a b sorry one a and a one b
one b one b option to b or not to b one
b like you know one a
option option one option no I think I
think the process users to
eliminate the process will be buses or
traffic through wner or not and that's
Satisfied by one or two and if we've got
a tolerance for one then we can decide a
bit more about what one looks like and
I'm open to having some discussion about
one or 1 a and if somebody's got some
modification that's a little bit more
insightful so there we'll have the
discussion but I'd like us to make a
decision tomorrow and not be no one B
well you can try one if you want to what
should one
be yeah but
if if we if we take the clock out and
move it will be an effect will just be
one that's what one does one just takes
everything out and it opens up a oneway
street we'll keep the columns columns
still St the column yeah the columns are
another another bate for another time
because we need a device on it but
option one goes what I'm saying is
option one goes through the of the stage
you could you could get rid of the clock
and still slip around yeah and keep the
columns so oh absolutely yeah the
columns are IR relevant to one or two
theor really is the columns is if it's
one
gone we we discuss lat stage when we get
some more bison
Russell
sorry well no as you heard as you heard
Russell say regard we go to one or 1 a
we will get some design features back
from Russell and from John Green's team
to say what it would look
like core is core issue is traffic
through or no
traffic um just to reminder the council
that currently two does not have the
clock in it either two is um wner
Redevelopment so you might if you're
considering two you might want a 2 a
which is uh clock staying as well so
just a reminder that that two is a
Redevelopment of wner no buses going
through but also no
clock and I think the report actually
says that with a preference for I think
that's what it actually if you read the
recommendation it
says yeah it's recommended to be delete
one with the with Council having a
preference
for um it says I think if I recall
rightly it says to retain the clock
retain the column so
I guess the intention is that you can
modify
that as as you see fit during your
debate
sure interest tactical voting tomorrow
y